as it becomes clearer Ron backed away
from conflict the media's seek a new
spin Joy Behar in the crowded the view
discover they actually like neo-nazi
Richard Spencer and Mitch McConnell vows
not to take advice from Nancy Pelosi I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN stand up for your digital
rights visit expressvpn comm slash Ben
well the last 72 hours over the last
week has been a major win for the Trump
administration why because as I have
been stating ever since soleimani was
killed the Trump administration has
reestablished a long-forgotten doctrine
known as deterrence and it's amazing to
watch people in the media all of the
Talking Heads all of the wonks tell you
the deterrence is something that doesn't
exist could never have existed
with Iran all of that predicated on
their worship for Barack Obama who was a
magical magical man in their view the
way this worked is that brought
President Barack Obama had done
something magical he had basically
converted Iran into Sweden all he had to
do was sign a few checks to the mullahs
and then they would abandon their
nuclear program not just for the ten
years specified by contract but for all
time and as for the terrorism and the
ballistic missile testing in the
development of terrorist groups all
around the region and the interference
in Iraq and Lebanon and Syria and Saudi
Arabia and Yemen all of that well we
were just ignored that because Barack
Obama had done something magical and
Barack Obama's narrative had always been
they either signed the check to the
mullahs or alternatively that you go to
war with them those were the only two
alternatives there was no third
alternative and then Donald Trump came
along and he said you know what there's
this thing that we used to do here it's
called deterrence deterrence and that
this works right for Trump Trump doesn't
have to understand the totality of
deterrence theory because the theory is
really quite simple
and Trump gets it because he gets it in
most areas of his own life which is you
threaten some somebody with something
worse than they are threatening you with
they threaten you that they're going to
bring a knife you threaten to bring a
gun writes the Chicago away a Trump at
least gets that much and so when it came
to Soleimani basically the Iranians kept
upping the ante upping the ante and
Trump kept ignoring it because he did
not want a conflict in the Middle East
he's the only president of my lifetime
who has not been in an overt shooting
war in the Middle East and the president
of the United States finally had had
enough and he said okay you tried to
burn our embassy we're gonna take out
your big bad terrorists Soleimani cuz
I'm Soleimani and the media said oh what
war is now inevitable now we're gonna
have World War three and Trumbull said
well not really
not so much this is called deterrence
right the Iranians are now on notice
that there are such things as lines and
if you cross those lines there will be
consequences and
gave the lie to the media's coverage of
Barack Obama Obama was exposed but he'd
been exposed already I mean the Iranians
were getting more and more militant even
in the aftermath of the nuclear deal the
nuclear deal was signed in 2013 the the
nominee for u.s. CENTCOM by the Obama
administration said in March 2016 that
the Iranians had actually become more
aggressive in the wake of the Iran
nuclear deal because they had more money
to play with and they knew that the only
thing the West's cared about was the
nuclear weapons development not the
expansion of terrorism and terror growth
around the region so the media had that
Barack Obama had already been exposed by
events but the media had not been
exposed the media could continue to
propagate the lies that had been fed to
them by Ben Rhodes who then went out and
bragged about how he lied to the media
and how they'd formed an echo chamber on
his behalf well now that Donald Trump
has shown over the last 72 hours that
the laws of political gravity did not
cease to apply with Barack Obama that
there is such a thing in foreign
relations as actual deterrence the media
have been completely and utterly exposed
for the fools that they are and what
this is created is a need for the media
to now defend their flank the media now
needs to come up with an alternative
explanation for how things just went so
right for Donald Trump that Soleimani is
dead and the Iranians were so cowed that
you are seeing the pmf the the terror
group those responsible for the
attempted burning of the US Embassy in
Baghdad basically backing off their open
calls by people like Matata al Sadr
who's the leader of Shia Muslims in Iran
in Iraq there are calls by him for the
PMF to disband as a functioning entity I
mean all of that is a result of Donald
Trump using some deterrence and so the
media have to come up with an
alternative explanation and as we'll see
their alternative explanation as the
Donald Trump continues to be a nut and a
very stupid nut and that we ought to
trust the ayatollahs and we ought to
trust Barack Obama and we ought to trust
them and so what they're doing now is
they're talking up the possibility of
war even though it is absolutely clear
at this point that Iran has backed away
from the war again there was another
report today that the Iranians had
basically warned the Iraqis the
administration's denying this as they
should I mean they should deny this
because the fact is that if the Iranians
were trying to save face then suggesting
to the world that the Iranians called up
the United States and said guys get your
guys out of there because we just need
to save face here if the US were to
spill that on the world stage then that
wouldn't assess it eight more Iranian
action presumably so the u.s. basically
saying yeah no that
meant to harm us they just weren't able
to do so it's a better line than yeah
the Iranians completely chickened out
and they called us and told us to get
our guys out of the way so that they
could save a little bit of face that's
what Mike Pence was saying today for
example that this was a strike those
meant to kill and we just had this great
early warning system we're counting me a
little skeptical on that point but the
media continued to play up the
possibility of war because they just
can't accept the fact that Iran has
always been violent that the possibility
of war that existed six months ago
existed three years ago existed eight
years ago existed 20 years ago and will
continue to exist years from now but
that it has not been heightened by the
United States taking a hard-line
position in fact it has been decreased
in terms of intensity and possibility of
scope by the fact that they have been
deterred from future action
well Iran hasn't changed its regional
orientation and the United States has
not changed its regional orientation the
difference is that Iran knows it can't
get away with as much and so they are
going to scale back some of their more
overt terror activity doesn't mean the
problem is solved it does mean that
Donald Trump has backed them off of a
lot of the activities that they were
pursuing that we're getting more and
more overtly aggressive still the media
are gonna point there they're gonna play
up the possibility that we're still at
war and that right now we are still in
danger of launching into an immediate
full-scale war and so you get articles
like this from the Associated Press the
u.s. and Iran step back from the brink
of possible war on Wednesday as
President Donald Trump signaled he would
not retaliate militarily for Ahrens
missile strikes on Iraqi bases housing
US troops no one was harmed in the
strikes but the US forces in the region
remained on high alert speaking from the
White House Trump seemed intent on
escalating the crisis which spiraled
after he authorized the targeted killing
last week of Iran's top General Qasem
Soleimani
did it spiral after that or was it you
know like the burning of the embassy the
shooting down of the American drone the
destruction of Saudi oil facilities the
bombing of ships in the Strait of Hormuz
according to media it's always about
Trump because the world began Trump is
like gods of these people or the devil
the world began spinning as soon as he
spake the words we'll get to more of the
media's malfeasance on all of this
momentarily first let's talk about
changing your lifestyle this year so a
lot of people in the aftermath of the
new year they make resolutions about how
they're gonna get healthier this year
and really what they mean is thinner but
the reality is you do need to get
healthier because when you get healthier
you're probably also going to get
thinner and that means a lifestyle
change not just like a workout change
and not just a diet change a change in
the way
you view the world the change in your
actual day-to-day habits this is where
noon comes in noon is a is a way of
adjusting your lifestyle itself they
teach you the psychology behind the
decisions you make and then help you
keep track of everything from workouts
and steps to analyzing your diet and
recommending health recipes new mom also
connects you with the personally
assigned goal specialist so it's a way
of having somebody basically coach you
through the day gives you every step
that you could possibly need and it
helps you change your entire lifestyle
your entire set of habits Newton gives
you the tools you just have to decide to
change your life for the better so for
me a big thing is how I eat and calorie
counting noon does have a tool that
helps you with all that but they're also
giving you helpful tips throughout the
day on how you can mitigate your
cravings for example based in psychology
Noom teaches you why you do the things
you do and empowers you with the tools
you need to break bad habits and replace
them with better ones this is really
really important psychology is important
when it comes to changing your lifestyle
and newman knows that you don't have to
change all of it in one day small steps
make big progress sign up for your trial
today at noon that's n om comm slash am
Pierrot again that is Numa comm slash
should be no Ross strapped for time but
new masks to to commit just ten minutes
a day for yourself and it'll make your
life very different what do you have to
lose visit new Montcalm slash shapiro to
start your trial today that's n om comm
slash shapiro so the AP is already
talking up the possibility of further
wide-scale conflicts which is really not
in the offing it will be low-level
conflict as it was before according to
the AP though despite such conciliatory
talk the region remained on edge
American troops including a quick
reaction force dispatched over the
weekend were on high alert well that
makes sense I mean you're gonna want to
continue to be on high alert but the
idea that we're going to full-scale war
now is I think pretty much off the table
since the Iranians really backed down
what what's hilarious won't get to the
media response in a second is that the
the House Democrats in an attempt to
backfill a hole that they dug for
themselves right we were in the middle
of World War 3 according to the
Democrats Trump had brought us to the
brink of World War three everyone was
gonna go die everybody stockpile food
get water make sure they got your water
purification tablets I mean it was just
gonna be a mess zombies in the streets
chaos everywhere
dogs and cats sleeping together it was
gonna be insane right this was the
Democratic narrative and then none of
that happened to Ron just back down
which is what smaller countries do when
faced with the greatest military
fighting force in the
the world as it turns out so now Nancy
Pelosi and the members of the House are
trying to backfill that and make Trump
look like a bad guy
even though Trump won this round he did
hey the Americans in the United States
won this round so what are house
democrats doing well now house democrats
have merged yesterday from a classified
briefing on wednesday deeply skeptical
of president donald trump's decision to
order the killing of a top Iranian
leader and unconvinced he posed an
imminent threat to the United States
okay first of all the definition of
imminent threat I think needs to be
assessed here so what you're seeing in
the media is imminent threat means we
had a very specific knowledge of the
specific plan that the specific
terrorist was engaged in and thus we had
to kill him because tomorrow he was
gonna do something the Trump
administration used the word imminent in
sort of a broader sense I think the
sense that most of us use it when we
talk about terrorism in other words were
there working plans in place to harm
America and her interest when it comes
to Soleimani that was basically his day
job this is like asking as noah rothman
at commentary magazine put it whether a
Dunkin Donuts there preparing to make
donuts that day
that's what Soleimani did for a living
hey slowly Mounties job was to plan
terror attacks that's why Mike Pompeo
the Secretary of State when when asked
about imminence he said well like me
last week they burned our embassy and
the week before that they were shooting
rockets at our bases so seems like a
pretty good bad that he was not going to
suddenly turn into he was not gonna
suddenly turn into a monk and go live at
a monastery well heard the congressman
from Texas who in fact has been rather
trump skeptical he came out he said I
think that an attack from Soleimani was
imminent because that's literally what
the man did are you convinced that an
attack from Soleimani was imminent
against Americans um I do and you had
some very sophisticated consumers of
intelligence that talked about how
credible this information was there was
a level of specificity but I could go
even further beyond this immediate
threat a costume sulemani has been a
threat and an acute threat to the United
States for a very long time and taking
him off the
Fields has had a significant impact it
showed the Iranian regime that there's
going to be consequences to their reign
of terror I mean what what exactly was
at Hama bin Laden's imminent threat when
he was killed the answer is probably not
much because he was essentially isolated
in his compound in Pakistan's that mean
it was illegal for the United States to
kill him absolutely not
yet House Democrats are now trying to
complain that it was illegal what's the
purpose of this seriously what's about
the same House Democrats who cheered
when Barack Obama violated the War
Powers Resolution when they cheered I
mean he literally started a war in Libya
and then just stayed there he killed
moammar qaddafi for no apparent reason
truly no parries and other than his
belief that Qaddafi was engaged in human
rights violations but Qaddafi at that
point was funneling us information
Qaddafi had been neutralized as a threat
to the West and the war in Libya ended
with vast swaths of refugees entering
Europe and with the burning of the
American Embassy in Benghazi it ended
with the provisional government of Libya
having to try to govern with no
available forces from boats offshore it
was a complete disaster the war in Libya
the the Obama administration pushed it
anyway to the cheers of Nancy Pelosi now
Nancy Pelosi is like well we need to
restrict the president's ability to
strike and right now listen on a
principled level should the President of
the United States have the kind of
war-making authority that he has been
granted over the last several decades
the answer is no the Constitution of the
United States declares that Congress
should have the authority to declare war
the presidents of the United States must
have the ability to respond quickly to
threats because you don't have time to
just get a session of Congress together
when there's a terrorist attacking you
to kill a terrorist for example so even
under the most I think strict
circumstances it would be difficult to
argue that it's unconstitutional for
Trump to shoot a missile at soleimani
but for broader sort of engagements the
idea that you need congressional
approval makes a lot of sense I mean the
fact is that the the Congress of the
United States has basically been
rendered a vestigial organ when it comes
to the declaration of war in nineteen in
1970s was 1973 the War Powers Resolution
was brought to the fore that suggests
that the President of the United States
can get involved in Foreign Wars
basically for a period of I believe 60
days under the War Powers Act and then
he has to go to Congress for
reauthorization it has basically been
ignored ever since the United States has
not had a single declared war formally
declared war since World War two the
Vietnam
or was not a declared war the Gulf War
was not a declared war Gulf War - was
not a declared war there was an
authorization for use of military force
those passed by Congress in the
aftermath of September 11th the
interpretation of that document has been
widely variants did it cover a rock
unclear did it cover activities outside
the Afghanistan sphere probably how far
did it go not clear
does it cover what's going on right now
in Iraq or Iran you know 20 years later
unclear so the idea that Congress should
seize back some of its war-making
authority under the Constitution I
actually am very much in favor of simply
because I think that when a Democrat is
in power it would be better if Congress
were able to check the power of any
president I'm not in favor of the broad
expansion of executive authority but
that what I'm saying here is that the
House Democrats picked a very weird hill
to die on that now all of a sudden it's
well Trump has challenged congressional
authority by any standard what Trump did
to soleimani is so much less than
anything that Barack Obama did for eight
years droning America on rocky who is a
terrorist was also an American citizen
Obama droned him and you'll remember
that Rand Paul got up and did a
filibuster of the overt over that drone
attack saying well that guy's still an
American citizen you don't just get to
drone him they can think that Rand Paul
is wrong but the suggestion that Trump
droning an Iranian terrorist who was in
Iraq planning terror attacks that's why
he was there I mean who's literally
meeting with the head of the PMF they
were in the same car that's why they're
both dead today the idea that that is
violation of presidential authority but
Barack Obama for eight long years was
not violating executive authority in
launching undeclared wars in Libya a
full-scale drone war across Africa in
the Middle East you're gonna have to
explain that one to me Democrats
Democrats don't have an explanation it
really is not driven by any real
principle all this is driven by is anger
that President Trump showed them up
because that's all that happened here
remember they didn't try to press this
resolution in the aftermath of from
firing a missile into Syria after Syria
gasps some of its own citizens again
they didn't try anything like this
why because Obama had done exactly the
same thing with Syria except less here
the problem was that Obama that Trump
humiliated Obama he humiliated the
Democrats and now they're going to seize
that congressional authority supposedly
under the auspices that Soleimani was
not an imminent threat yeah you really
are gonna have to explain why it was
illegal or bad to kill Soleimani you're
really gonna need to explain that before
you start discussing how Trump did a
very
thing and this is why you're gonna come
in moment I'm gonna distinguish between
some of the right-wing conservative
opposition to executive authority coming
from people like Mike Lee and to a
certain extent Rand Paul and the
left-wing anger at executive authority
which is coming purely from a place of
we hate Donald Trump we don't like that
he humiliated Barack Obama and how we
are going to check the executive
authority we'll get to all of that in
just one second first safety and
security number-one priority for me
number-one priority for my wife
unfortunately because we're high-profile
figures I'm a high-profile figure that
means that we do get a lot of death
threats it means that the FBI has
arrested people for threatening to kill
me and my family and that means that I
want to make sure that my home security
is absolutely top-notch the people I
trust with my home security are the
folks over at ring their job is to make
your home and your neighborhood safer
they're smart video doorbells and
cameras protect millions of people
everywhere so I can know what's going on
at home literally right now I can just
pull out my phone and I can check my
property if somebody steps sets foot on
my property I get an alert if I'm a
thousand miles away ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you do get an
alert and you're able to see here and
speak to them all from your phone I've
had great experience with ring I've been
using them for literally years they've
created this ring of security around my
house it's made me feel so much more
secure and when somebody is creeping
when I hear the alarm go off in the
middle of the night I can check it from
my phone instead of having to creep
around my house of the shotgun that
definitely is an upgrade to my lifestyle
as a subscriber you have a special offer
on a ring welcome kit available right
now at ring.com slash Ben the kit
includes a video doorbell and a chime
Pro which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go to ring.com
slash Ben that is ring.com slash man go
check them out right now okay so Nancy
Pelosi on Wednesday announced that the
house would vote on Thursday to limit
Trump's war-making powers likely
presenting a United Democratic Front
against the administration's recent
moves against Tehran so they are now
opposing the moves that box in Iran this
is now the formal Democratic position
not that they have a general objection
way that might lead us to executive
authority but that they have a specific
objection to what Trump just did in Iran
which is insane because this is the most
successful foreign policy move since
really maybe the end of the Reagan
administration but certainly since since
call for one the bottom line to this is
that
Ron was backed off of its aggression
they were backed off and they lost their
top commander
they lost their top terror commander who
was by all accounts the most effective
person in Iran and they were Andy and
the Democrats are angry about it they're
upset about it why again not because
they believe that the Congressional
Authority has been violated Barack Obama
did it routinely
the reason they're upset is because
Donald Trump gave the lie to the Obama
administration's lie and now they've
been exposed so here is Nancy Pelosi
saying we're gonna vote on a War Powers
Resolution Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi putting out a statement
moments ago saying that a War Powers
Resolution would be will be voted on in
the house tomorrow War Powers Resolution
she says to quote limit the president's
military actions regarding Iran and this
legislation is going to the Rules
Committee and she says will be voted on
tomorrow in the house okay I know that
we're all ignoring the fact that the
Iranians tried to burn our embassy in
Baghdad last week but imagine the kind
of insanity it takes to hate Trump so
much that the Iranians burn an American
Embassy and your first move is we've got
to limit the president from Italia ting
we have to limit the president from
responding again now coming from a place
of principled opposition to executive
use of commander-in-chief power but
coming from we just don't like that
Trump has exposed our entire ideology on
foreign policy and the way political
reports this is just ridiculous
lawmakers from across the house
Democratic caucus left a closed-door
meeting with top Trump administration
officials in a secure room in the
capital on Wednesday frustrated if not
outright angry and what they described
is a vague justification for last week's
deadly drone strike that killed Iranian
major general Qasim sulemani shortly
after he arrived in Baghdad so they're
angry that we killed sulemani they're
angry at the justification which is that
he was involved in the burning of the
United States embassy last week this is
what they are angry at seriously Pramila
jeyapaul Democrat of Washington and
co-chair of the Congressional
Progressive Caucus which is she's kind
of an adjunct member of the squad she
says there was no raw evidence presented
that this was an imminent threat okay so
he's only a non Hindman threat meaning
that I guess two weeks from now he was
going to murder Americans but we didn't
know if he was gonna murder Americans
like specifically tomorrow here is
jeyapaul announcing that Trump
recklessly assassinated Soleimani I mean
this is doing the PR work of the
Iranians this is the result of reckless
actions by President Trump of military
brinksmanship president Trump recklessly
assassinated Qasem Soleimani he had no
evidence of an imminent threat or attack
and we say that coming from a classified
briefing where again there was no raw
evidence presented that there was an
imminent threat yeah again I'm gonna
need to know whether any of these
Democrats asked for the raw classified
information that led to the death of
Anwar al-awlaki what was the imminent
threat from Anwar al-awlaki
what was the imminent threat from Osama
bin Laden for that matter it turns out
that killing terrorists is authorized
under the authorization to use military
force that is pretty much the only thing
that is authorized under the AUMF that
was passed in the aftermath of 9/11 and
what this really is about is Democrats
being upset that Donald Trump did a
thing
that they don't like that expose their
entire ideology is why Jerry Connelly
out there going this briefing was
entirely unconvincing okay like again
where were you when Barack Obama was
declaring war in Libya without any
congressional authorization then
ignoring congressional blowback my
reaction of this briefing was it was
sophomoric and utterly unconvincing and
I believe more than ever the Congress
needs to act to protect the
constitutional provisions about warrant
peace they're freaking was no rationale
that could could pass a graduate school
thesis test I was well utterly
unpersuaded about any evidence about the
imminence of a threat that was new or or
compelling ok well even if that had been
presented do you really think the
Democrats would be out there today
saying well I guess that was new and
compelling I guess that everything is
fine now do you really think that that's
the case these I really don't think that
that is the case Mitch McConnell for his
part was slamming Nancy Pelosi over all
of this and he's exactly right to do so
as troubled me that speaker Pelosi
responded to the earliest reports
yesterday by leaping to blame quote
needless provocations by our
administration in other words blaming
the United States so let's be clear we
can and should debate how to responsibly
respond to Iranian thrust but the notion
the notion that our administration is to
blame for Iranian aggression mr.
president that's nonsense
well of course it is nonsense and again
the fact that the Democrats are so
opposed to what happened with Iran has
little to do with the actual action with
regard to Iran and much more to do with
protect the precious as always Barack
Obama now I will say there is such a
thing as principled opposition to what
just happened in Iran
it comes from two places one is an
actual anti interventionist stance right
in the actual isolationist stance that's
held by senators like Rand Paul and then
there's the sort of constitutional
perspective which is that the President
of the United States the other party
should not have the kind of authority
that is routinely used by presidents of
both parties that's sort of the position
of Mike Lee from Utah Mike Lee was
fulminating after the briefing the way
the Democrats were - saying that he was
going to support the Democrats War
Powers Resolution the only difference is
I think that Mike Lee would support it
whether it's against a Republican or a
Democrat I think the Democrats would
only support this against a Republican
these powers are not ours they don't
belong to any of us
but when we allow them to be exercised
through the wrong branches of government
with the wrong process when you don't
have debate in discussion you don't
allow the process itself to correct
itself for the American people who'll be
most affected by these decisions to
weigh in that was insulting that was
demeaning to the process ordained by the
Constitution and I find it completely
unacceptable
on that basis I've decided to support
senator Kane's resolution subject to the
minor amendments that he and I discussed
earlier today you know full disclosure
I'm very friendly with Senator Lee I
think that he's an excellent senator and
so perhaps I'm granting him the benefit
of the doubt but I do know his
constitutional perspective well enough
to know that this is a consistent
constitutional perspective that is not
true for the Democrats and the fact that
the Democrats are out there you know
praising Obama for his interventionism
I mean again he did start shooting war
in Libya that his for his intervention
in the Middle East without any
congressional approval and in fact in
spite of congressional distinct want to
restrict War Powers that's that's a
cynical play the Democrats behavior here
is just amazing the fact that Ilhan Omar
in open anti-semite who openly
sympathizes with the ayatollahs I mean
she put out a tweet yesterday about
economic sanctions against Iran
suggesting that economic sanctions our
form of warfare which is weird because
she doesn't really care about an in fact
she supports sanctions against the
[Music]
Julian Omar really does not like them
Jews she's very much in favor of BDS
against Israel a democratic ally of the
United States but she says economic
sanctions against Iran are very bad
shocking
yesterday she did this press conference
where Ilhan omar expressed that she had
post-traumatic stress disorder thanks to
tensions with Iran well clearly we
should formulate our foreign policy
based on the fact that Ilhan Omar is
having flashbacks or something I feel
ill a little bit because of of
everything that is taking place and I
think every time I hear about come a
year of conversations around war I find
myself being stricken with PTSD
and I I find peace knowing that I I
serve with great advocates for for peace
and and people who have shown courage
against war are we supposed to are we
supposed to take this human being
seriously this is a human being we were
supposed to take seriously a person who
once wrote letters in support of people
who had joined Isis asking the judge for
more mercy upon them this did happen in
Minnesota well reported by the minion
Minneapolis star-tribune she sits on the
House Foreign Affairs Committee despite
the fact that she says an anti-semitic
thing approximately once every 30 2.9
seconds this human being who says yes
clearly we should form we should
formulate our Ronn policy around Ilhan
Omar because she feels a little a little
ill she feels a little ill really is it
that okay what this is about for people
or not Ilhan Omar who's just a radical
who is not cold
she's lukewarm at best with regard to
America's anti-terror efforts let's just
put it that way the the mainstream
Democratic players are more focused on
how much they hate Trump than they are
about the interests of the United States
and that is pretty obvious James clapper
the former head of the Central
Intelligence Agency under Barack Obama
he suggested that you know when we were
paying off the Iranians that wasn't us
paying off the Iranians we were just
giving them the money that they had
already earned I mean we were just
freeing up their money I've heard this
talking point from many members of the
left that when the Obama administration
shipped pallets of cash to Iran and gave
them a hundred and fifty billion dollars
and that wasn't bad because after all
that it was money that had been earned
by the Iranian government I mean that
was money that was owed to the Iranian
government okay well you know what's a
thing that we do here in the United
States let's say that the drug dealer
gets arrested for being a drug dealer we
seize his assets one of the reasons we
seize his assets is because we don't
want him using those assets for further
drug dealing the notion that well you
know that drug dealer really did earn
that money I guess we should just sign
that check over a uniquely foolish
position from the Obama administration
that was pursued to the hilt and led to
the rise in terror it is not as though
we provided taxpayer money to the
Iranians what we did was the
administration did was unfreeze assets
that were actually the Iranians
the weapons security assistance funding
for a weapon systems that we were
providing the Iraqis way back when so we
freed that up in the actual evident
intelligence evidence that I saw before
I left it didn't indicate they use much
of that for the supporting their
nefarious activities what they're gonna
do in any event regardless
money is fungible its fungible they'd
have to use that specific earmarked
dollar for buying a ballistic missile if
they use that specific earmarked dollar
for something else and then used a
different dollar for the ballistic
missile the dollar still went for the
ballistic missile ridiculous okay but
the media really have been shining
themselves they really are just outdoing
themselves on a regular basis so if you
ever had doubts that the media and the
Democratic Party are just wings of one
another that the Democratic Party is the
activist wing of the media and the media
are the PR wing for the Democrats all
you had to do is watch the media this
week who are doing the overt work of the
Obama administration which is to say the
overt work of the Iranian PR agencies
because effectively the Obama
administration became a PR agency for
the Iranians in order to push the Iran
deal the Obama administration had to
make the case that the Iranians were
good reasonable decent people who are
going to moderate and who are going to
become friends to the world community so
long as we appease them and so what you
saw from the Obama administration over
and over is that when Iran would do
something terrible it would be well know
you're just getting around wrong guys
you're just getting Iran wrong basically
the Obama administration became the
girlfriend to the abusive drug addict by
friend trying to explain her boyfriend
to her parents that was what the Obama
administration became with regard to the
Iranian government say well you know
he's he's not that bad guy sure you see
the bruise here like yeah he hit me but
I mean I did offend him to be fair and
yeah he's a drug addict who like hey who
tried to prostitute me for money but
let's be fair I mean he had a rough
childhood
that was the Obama administration with
regard to Iran and the media started
doing the same thing and now they
continued to do the same thing
the media's take on all of this is so
patently removed from reality that it
should destroy their credibility in a
massive way for a huge period of time it
won't of course because once you have
authoritative voices standing in Tehran
well that means they know things
alternately they don't know a damn thing
and many of them are unbelievably stupid
and or dishonest we'll get to that in
just one second first if you're are not
already a subscriber you are truly
missing out
head on over to daily wire comm slash
subscribe for as little as 10 bucks a
month you get our articles had free
access to all of our live broadcast our
full show library select bonus content
are exclusive at daily wire app which is
a pretty great feature if you haven't
checked it out yet
if you choose the new All Access plan
you'll get all of that plus the
legendary leftist ears tumblr and our
brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis oh come on stop
depriving yourself come join the fun
head on over to daily wire comm and
subscribe we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so the media simply cannot bring
themselves to acknowledge the overt
reality which is this was a win for
America and it was a win for Trump and
there's some members of the media who
don't really like from very much or at
least on an honest enough to admit this
I head on Ian Bremmer yesterday who's a
foreign policy analyst for g0 media
teachers I believe at Georgetown and Ian
is certainly no Trump fan and he said
Iran is weaker than it was when Trump
took office and Trump just opened a
window for negotiation and Trump has
actually reestablished a level of
deterrence of Iran that the Obama
administration had completely avoided at
least Ian is honest most of the members
of the media not nearly as honest how do
you know because they were just
repeating Iranian propaganda while the
Iranian retaliation was going on here is
MSNBC reporting false dead Americans
during the attack those were just
notices that were put out by the
Iranians honestly it's an amazing thing
they do the same thing with regard to
Israel and its enemies whenever the
Palestinians got when the government
authorities in the Gaza Strip for
example put out casualty numbers the
media just repeated without even
checking it and those casualty numbers
are always inflated and always refused
to take into account military age males
were actually members of terrorist
groups well they did the same thing
MSNBC did the same thing in the middle
of this attack they just started
repeating false numbers about dead
Americans that didn't exist al Asad Air
Base and there being 30 casualties I
just want to be very clear we don't have
independent confirmation of that as of
yet that is a claim being made on
Iranian state media to Iran state media
is claiming the thirty US soldiers have
been killed in this attack and out this
is not confirmed this is just coming
from Iranian media but we have just
stepped over the precipice Chris you've
stepped over the precipice based on the
report from Iranian state media that was
a full-on lie that had no merit to it
whatsoever sure when we're not gonna
take it too seriously but you wish take
it SuperDuper seriously and every
element of what Trump has done along the
way has been criticized for the dumbest
possible reason if you go on Twitter
today people are criticizing the fact
that Trump sniffs during his speeches
there's been a thing during his speeches
for a very long time they're suggesting
that the reason he sniffs is because
he's on adderall they're criticizing the
fact that he was that he was slurring a
couple of his words yeah how about the
fact that Joe Biden cannot string
together a human sentence how about the
fact that Nancy Pelosi bobbles her words
routinely but but Donald Trump is a very
bad man because of that Nemus NBC
panel yesterday could not even believe
that military brats were attending Trump
speech
how could military brass here's Ben
Rhodes the vicious liar going after the
Trump administered the military brass
attend Trump speech even though they
were the ones who had presided over the
attack it's just sad that we're still
sitting here with a president United
States who out of a weird mixture of
envy and deep antipathy has to attack
his predecessor in the most political
manner with the military standing behind
him discussing life or death issues it
just shouldn't come to this Nicole we're
better than this our politics should be
better than this is a damn liar he's a
damn liar a repeated damn Ned liar he's
just awful in every way and he's an
Obama administration advocate sitting
how dare Donald Trump exploit the
military this way Barack Obama literally
went to an airbase I believe is in
Afghanistan and suggested that the
soldiers made a great photo-op that's a
direct quote okay it's it's enough to
boggle the mind the gas lighting is
unbelievable and speaking of obsessions
I guess I'm about Trump being obsessed
with Obama it's about the fact that
Trump just showed up Obama and that
Obama's legacy is a bag of flaming dog
poop okay Obama's legacy on Iraq is
horrific and it was led by Ben Rhodes
who's led by Susan Rice and what are the
media do they go get Ben Rhodes and
Susan Rice like why is Trump so obsessed
with us why is from so obsessed with us
also why is Trump such an ugly orange
man the projection here is just
astonishing meanwhile you have columnist
for The New York Times trying to pretend
that a win is a law so you got Nicholas
Kristof / the New York Times who has a
piece today says Trump has a bizarre
idea of winning here's what he says for
now we seem to averted an all-out
shooting war between the United States
and Iran yet it's not over the world is
more dangerous than it was a week ago no
it most assuredly is not soleimani
was a massive chess piece he is off the
board the Iranians are backing off of
aggression inside Iraqis they don't want
to cross red lines no the world is not
more dangerous than it was before most
assuredly it is not president Trump's
exuberance says Nicholas Kristof
suggests that he may have learned
precisely the wrong lesson from his
clash with Iran
Trump and some of his supporters are
crowing at the lack of American
casualties Iran may have carefully aims
to miss people in ways the remind me of
the hubris preceding the 2003 invasion
of Iraq as the
there were then there are today concerns
about whether intelligence has been
overstated leaders are thumping their
chests and there's too much confidence
in the ability of the military toolbox
to solve complex problems so he can't
actually explain why this was a bad
thing so he's just gonna go back to the
Iraq war which in popular revisionist
history was a complete loss for the
United States if I despite the fact that
the original aim of the war which was to
depose Saddam Hussein was accomplished
inside of three words thing in three
weeks thanks to the greatest military in
the history of the world
but according to colas Christoph this is
a big loss why well Trump who in 2012
repeatedly claimed that Barack Obama
would start a war with Iran's help line'
reelection is already running election
ads on facebook trumpeting his killing
of Major General Kasim sulemani and
stating that this is keeping America
safe so again Trump did not quote
unquote start a war with Iran to win
reelection that's absurdity at the
highest level and killing solely money
is a good thing I'm sorry the Democrats
are finding it hard to campaign against
killing terrorists but you guys picked
that position you didn't have to but
here is how an ich allez Christoph
characterizes the results you ready this
is idiotic Iran has cast off nuclear
curbs so that it is now potentially
within five months of having enough fuel
for a nuclear warhead
down from almost 15 years when Trump
took office it was not 15 years when
Trump took office that was their
voluntary statement that they would not
develop nuclear weapons for quote
unquote 15 years the nuclear deal didn't
even extend for 15 years and extended
for 10 years and their development of
nuclear weapons was a secondary priority
for them next to their development of
regional power which they had been
pursuing pedal to the metal
ever since the Iran nuclear deal United
States forces according to Christoph may
be pushed out of Iraq allowing suleimani
to achieve and death one of his foremost
goals in life I need some evidence there
and I don't wanna hear your bullcrap
about the Iraqi parliament voting to
eject the United States they don't even
have the power to do that it takes a
cabinet request the cabinet doesn't
exist
the reason the cabinet does not exist in
Iraq is because the president the prime
minister of Iraq does does not have any
authority he's the acting prime minister
because of protests inside his own
country that were suggesting that he was
in thrall to Iran there's not support
inside Iraq by Shia but by by Sunnis
rather and Kurds for the United States
to pull out of there because they know
the moment that happens the Iranians
basically take over American forces in
Syria may be difficult to support
without the military presence in Iraq so
somewhere all of them might pull out as
well another strategic victory for Iran
wait a second are you
saying that pulling troops out of the
region would be a victory for Iran
because it was my impression the Barack
Obama precipitously precipitously
withdrew all troops from Iraq or nearly
all troops from Iraq leading to the rise
of Isis leading to the continuation of
Syria leading to Russia taking over
Syria and Iran funding Syria Nicholas
Kristof man I mean that the disconnect
from any some people have memory
they're like Dory from Finding Nemo they
got memories that last for 32 seconds
it's unbelievable it's incredible the
military campaign against Isis on hold
giving terrorists a chance to regroup
and we need some evidence of that Iran's
regime which had been threatened by
enormous protests at home and in Iraq
has been rescued by Trump's actions
rescued by Trump's actions truly they've
killed 15 hundred protesters listen when
you talk about regime change yeah first
of all Christoph and the rest of left
don't want the regime changed in Iran
Barack Obama didn't want the regime
changed in Iran who want to strengthen
the regime in Iran hey but if you're
talking about regime change in Iran
there's only one real way that's
happening from inside the Iranian
military because the people do not have
anything like these sort of ability to
overthrow the military that they had in
other countries where the military was
smaller the fact is that as long as the
military support the moas the mullahs
will remain in power it will take
somebody in the military changing his
mind in order for that to change but
they're been roiling protests across
Iran for literally years at this point
and I'm old enough to remember in 2009
when the Iranians were out in the
streets protesting by the hundreds of
thousands and around in troops were
gunning them down and Barack Obama did
nothing nothing to help nothing but
according to Nicholas Kristof Iranians
have rallied around the flag in the
Iraqi narrative has changed overnight
from the bullying of Iran ian's to the
bullying of Americans really is that
what the Iraqi narrative is because it
seems that the Iranians just fired
actual ballistic missiles into a foreign
nation instead of bringing troops home
Trump has had to deploy more to the
Middle East at huge cost wait a second
two points ago and Nicholas Kristof was
arguing that we should not bring any of
those troops home because it would free
up the Middle East for Isis and for Iran
now he's arguing that Trump should bring
the troops home it's a like the
narrative will shift just so that Trump
is bad that's all so much winning in
there will be Morris's Nicholas Kristof
it's true that iran's Foreign Minister
Javad Zarif said that Iran's response
had concluded but Zarif is a moderate
often outmaneuvered by hardliners I know
this partly because back in 2004 after
Zarif approved a visa for me I was
detained in Iran by security forces
looking for information that could embed
Arif and get him fired oh well Nicholas
Kristof his friends with Zarif that
means he's moderate so we're still
hearing echoes of the Ben Rhodes crap
that there is a moderate faction inside
the Iranian government that is being
challenged by the hardliners inside the
Iranian government
it's like saying who's more Pro Trump
Ivanka or Trump like what are you even
talking about hey there are not two
parties here there's one part one-party
dictatorship then you have Jamelle Bouie
who just writes foolishness every week
for the New York Times the Trump we did
not want to see when are we going to
stop trying to rationalize the
irrational deterrence is not irrational
it is not irrational but according to
Jamelle Bouie is just the trump isn't
not he says this standoff which hidden
its latest incarnation saw Ronnie and
missile sailing to our bases in Iraq on
Tuesday night is so consequential it's
been hard not to impede some logic to
the president's actions even as many
observers acknowledge the lies and
dysfunctions surrounding the attack it's
only natural we're just looking for some
sort of logic but we've learned since
the strike on sulemani was almost
certainly another impulsive action from
an impatient president except for the
fact the New York Times reported that
Mike Pompeo had been pushing for silly
monies killing for literally months on
end he says the Trump is not a steady
hand he's never been one yada yada yada
so apparently Trump is the nut and it's
only thanks to the for the the
forethought of the Iranian regime that
everything is hunky-dory the Washington
Post editorial board today is insisting
that Trump didn't win I'm not owned I'm
not owned he shouted as he turned slowly
into a corn cob according to the
Washington Post proclaiming Trump
victorious in Iran is short-sighted and
premature oh really what was it when you
declared Obama victorious in Iran after
he decided to sign them check so they
could pursue further terrorism and
ballistic missile testing while
pretending that their nuclear program
was shut down for all time what would
you call that according to the
Washington Post mr. Trump's acolytes
quickly proclaimed him victorious for
having eliminated the architect of
Iran's foreign adventurism while
avoiding a more damaging response that
assessment was premature and
short-sighted
Iran's strikes on US interests and
allies will almost certainly continue in
the coming months
oh you mean as opposed to like before
when we had months on end of them firing
rockets and American military bases in
pursuing terrorist actions across the
Middle East unless the Trump
administration quickly steps up its
diplomatic game one supreme leader
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei called his
ultimate aim the removal of the United
States
the Middle East could soon be realized
in Iraq and Syria again based on no
evidence whatsoever but the media are
going to try to declare a victory in
actual loss because that's how much they
hate Trump
how much do members of the media hate
Trump yesterday on the view Joy Behar
mentioned that white supremacist Richard
Spencer won in the Charlottesville
leaders had decided that he would no
longer endorse Trump going into 2020 why
because Richard Spencer didn't like the
Trump had threatened quote/unquote Aryan
cultural heritage sites this is part of
this idiotic race nationalism that
suggests that first of all Persians are
Aryans and then second of all that that
Trump is is doing the view of the Trump
is pursuing the interests of the drawers
here's Joy Behar full scale
suggesting that Richard Spencer leaving
Donald Trump in terms of allegiance is a
good thing and then the entire crowd
cheering a white nationalist you
remember Richard Spencer he's basically
the organizer of unite the Ryan attack
the white nationalist group that was
marching in Charlottesville it's all in
for Trump not anymore
his his vote he tweeted last night I
deeply regret voting for and promoting
Donald Trump in 2016 oh my gosh ran are
not invading and not being that's what
I'm talking about I mean he free around
not invading it now welcome to the
resistance Richard Spencer okay when you
are praising a white nationalist to own
Trump you're doing everything wrong but
this is what there it's unbeatable do
just to avoid the obvious conclusion
which is that Trump gotta win here this
is what they will do it's on believable
they have Chris Matthews already say
that Trump keeps attacking Obama he's
keep attacking Obama I still means you
Obama boasts a nice guy gap here I kept
here every morning my replica coat
coming with a show come on in here I
explained and president Trump's a meanie
with regard to Obama as I love I love
Obama gives a tingle up my leg I
remember he signed that around nuclear
deal I basically orgasmed onstage was
crazy and now here I am explaining the
Trump he keeps attacked me Obama because
he made not because Obama's policy was
garbage please man go Chris Matthews go
in the midst of the international
conversation he
throws in this almost clinical need to
attack Obama it's almost like Tourette's
well can he not get through a
conversation without but in this case it
was so scarless he's basically saying as
you pointed out you see those bombs
hitting our American base in western
Iraq last night oh they were paid for by
Barack Obama like he's back there he's
the birth star he's the financial guy
behind these bombs it's been outrageous
stretch he's an outrageous stretch he
signed checks to the Iranians he opened
their economies they could pursue terror
Secretary of State drawing her announced
back in March 2016 that yes some of that
money would go to pursuing terror and
ballistic missiles but he's got like
threats he's so mean to him into a bomb
I love Obama I give that guy a back rub
right now he's beautiful sorry Kathleen
I'm busy tonight Chris Matthews over on
MSNBC the media have shamed themselves
if they had any if they had any
possibility of shame this would be a
shameful moment for them but good news
for them they have no capacity for shame
and so we will continue to lie to the
American people from the stage at MSNBC
already time for a quick thing that I
like and then we'll get to a quick thing
that I hate so things that I like so
first of all Nancy Pelosi has been
completely out maneuvered she had no
leverage when she held back the
impeachment charges she had no leverage
and none whatsoever
and everybody knew she had no leverage
but the media tried to proclaim that she
was a genius another another example of
the media being garbage at their jobs
the media tried to suggest that Nancy
Pelosi really had outplayed Mitch
McConnell ah you see if she doesn't hand
the charges to McConnell then she won't
have handed the charges to McConnell and
the McConnell won't be able to acquit
Trump and so then and then and then and
and and then chill won and she'll have
won guys because then she will not have
handed the impeachment charges to
McConnell and then McConnell will just
be sitting there then what's he gonna do
then what's he gonna do then he'll be
all mad wony cuz then he can't do
anything like he can't impeach Trump but
but show of impeach Trump but you won't
and they never made any sense basically
Nancy Pelosi was threatening to do a
thing McConnell didn't want anyway
and she was like Mitch McConnell if you
don't do what I want I will give you
this ice cream cone this ice cream cone
right here I will give it to you if you
don't do what I want you're not gonna do
it you want to hear a comes here comes
the ice cream here's the ice cream and
Mitch McConnell is like you gotta be
kidding me like this is incompetence at
the highest level it's ridiculous you
nothing that you have no leverage
nothing to threaten with the Republican
caucus is not going to agree to your
procedures on impeachment after you RAM
the house investigation in the dumbest
possible way refusing to call any of the
witnesses who are actually relevant or
wait for a judge to actually decide
whether those witnesses could be called
in the first place so Mitch McConnell
yesterday he's like no we're not
haggling over this you've got to be
kidding me
anybody who's proclaimed Nancy Pelosi a
master strategist has not been watching
the last year of Nancy Pelosi running
the house in the last year alone Nancy
Pelosi basically got played by the squad
and let's be frank about this the
combined IQ over at the squad if it were
electricity could not toast a piece of
bread lightly I mean those are not a set
of brilliant human beings over at the
squad they say dumb things routinely
they step in it all the time they say
openly anti-semitic things but Nancy
Pelosi could not even motivate her own
base to condemn anti-semitism in its own
resolution instead they'd put together a
huge resolution condemning all the bad
things including asparagus for dinner
because she just couldn't stand up to
the squad and so Nancy Pelosi lost
control of her own caucus men because
she'd lost control of her own caucus she
had to push for impeachment when censure
would have been a much easier move on
Ukraine and probably would draw on some
Republican votes instead she pushes
impeachment and then she's caught out
because it turns out that they don't
actually have the grounds for
impeachment they couldn't prove their
case which is the Trump was deliberately
attempting to sink Joe Biden not because
of concerns about corruption in Ukraine
not because of actual corruption
concerns about hunter Biden but
specifically because you want to Joe
Biden out of the way for 2020 they
couldn't prove it and then Nancy Pelosi
was like oh well I guess now that I'm
caught here well I'm just gonna give it
to you these impeachment charges now
this this right here this bag of poop
I'm gonna keep this bag of poop I'm
gonna put it in my refrigerator I'm
gonna let it stink up my fridge every
single day but you're never gonna
receive this bag of poop and mitch
mcconnell's like well i never wanted the
bag of poop if you want to hold that bag
of poop you can keep holding the bag of
poop it's a bag of poop explaining
supposedly the explanation for this
shameless game-playing is the speaker
policy wanted leverage leverage to reach
into the Senate and dictate our trial
proceedings to us
now I've made clear from the beginning
that no such leverage exists there will
be no haggling with a house / son and
procedure we will not cede our authority
to try this impeachment the House
Democrats turn is over the Senate has
made its decision
my favorite is animated Mitch McConnell
right there that is that is Mitch
McConnell getting animated you do have
to love the low-key nature of Mitch
McConnell on this sort of leverage
leverage are you out of your mind
according to Reuters the US Senate will
move forward with its own legislative
agenda next week unless it receives
articles of impeachment against Trump
from House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
McConnell said on Thursday he said on
the Senate floor there's real business
for the American people that the US
Senate needs to complete if the speaker
continues to refuse to take her own
accusations to trial the Senate will
move forward next week with the business
of our people in other words fine don't
send it see if I care why would I
possibly care if you're not sending it
so that that means that Nancy Pelosi has
now basically been boxed in but my
favorite thing is that you're not
allowed to say that Nancy Pelosi botched
this you must never say the Nancy Pelosi
botched this there was one Democratic
Congress person who actually said it his
name was Adam Smith Democrat of
Washington and he said we should be
sending these impeachment charges over
if we actually take them seriously and
then the entire Nancy Pelosi wing of the
media and the Democratic Party but I
repeat myself they came out there what
Adam Smith is a bad man Nancy Pelosi
he's a genius she's a genius guys she is
genius sing it up massive incredible
unbelievable unspoken genius you
challenged Nancy Pelosi she's on the
cover of Time magazine by the way this
week
Time magazine just another media
repository of idiocy on the cover piece
written by Molly ball titled her gamble
that's the and and so the idea is that
she there's no gamble here what is that
and then there's a picture of Nancy
Pelosi the media are so discussing like
they're just awful there's a picture of
Nancy Pelosi wit from behind slightly so
yeah I should get the halo of light
bouncing off of her well-groomed hair
and the headline is we've upped the ante
why Nancy Pelosi is going all-in against
Trump oh the heroism Oh
the unspeakable Molly ball rights Nancy
Pelosi isn't wild about the question the
impeachment of President Trump is
underway and I've asked the Speaker of
the House if she thinks it's the most
important thing she'll ever do we're
sitting in her elegant office in the
Capitol on gold upholstered armchairs
around the low tabletops of the vase of
hydrangeas one of my favorite things
about these sorts of long-form pieces is
the description of the surroundings
because it tells you everything you need
to know about the journalist that
description she's elegant right because
what they're saying about the
surroundings is the person right if it
were Donald Trump and her sitting in the
same place it would be Donald Trump
sitting in his vulgar office in the
White House surrounded by gold adorned
versailles furniture topped with a vase
of fake flowers but with Nancy Pelosi
it's her elegant office in the Capitol
on gold upholstered armchairs around a
low table top of the vase of hydrangeas
wow she's a queen in her own right it's
just it's amazing over her shoulder the
sweeping view of the National Mall is
shrouded in wintry clouds because this
team has to be set don't you see can't
you picture it in your mind's eye can't
you picture how the wintry clouds the
threat to democracy is coming over the
National Mall that symbol or Martin
Luther King once spoke ken with the
Washington Monument bus bolts of
lightning striking as Nancy Pelosi
stands up and picks up the hammer of
Thor according to Molly ball for a long
moment the speaker goes silent as she
seems to compile in her mind the list of
accomplishments she'd rather claim as
her legacy
apart from declaring war this is the
most important thing that Congress can
do she finally says I'm most proud of
the Affordable Care Act but this is the
most serious initiative I've ever been
involved in in my career Molly ball says
Pelosi has spent decades at the highest
level of politics but the past twelve
months have been arguably her most
consequential really she hasn't passed a
single piece of major legislation I'm
gonna go with the Obamacare Obamacare
was definitely the biggest thing she
ever did no question about it she's
correct about that but according to
Molly ball it's that she was part of the
resistance
risa stands for had and everything
whoo returning to the speakership after
eight years of running the House
Democratic minority she established
herself as a counterweight and constrain
ur of this divisive president she
outmaneuvered Trump on policy from the
border wall he didn't get so
budget agreement he signed loaded with
goodies that Democrats wanted she
oversaw an unprecedented litigation
effort against the executive branch
racking up landmark court victories oh
you mean there are a bunch of lower
courts that didn't like Trump and ruled
against him and then all of that was
overturned by the Supreme Court for the
most part and she was the tactician
behind the investigation that resulted
in Trump's impeachment on December 18th
that really took a huge amount of
tactics I mean what an amount of tactics
it took to say we're gonna investigate
the president for impeachment and then
your majority of Democrats that you run
actually impeach Wow the tactical
brilliance
I mean imagine it's like the tactical
brilliance if I were to pull my
employees about whether they liked the
show and then it turns out that most of
them say yes and the rest of them get
fired my tactical brilliance
unparalleled Nancy Pelosi said to her
own caucus you should impeach Trump and
then they'd impeach Trump boom mind
blown
tactical brilliance of having not a
single Republican on board not one just
on the woman his Clausewitz I mean what
can you say what is most striking
according to Molly ball about this
moment in Pelosi's career is that at the
peak of power she's not protecting her
position but rather using it and
aggressive even risky ways bullcrap if
she were pretty if she weren't
protecting her position she would've
condemned hill ahead Omar and receded
Talib and Ayana Presley and AOC and the
rest of the squad repeatedly but instead
she has kowtow to them of course she's
protecting her position she's been
protecting her left flank there's a
brief moment in time where it looked
like she's gonna challenge them and then
Trump got involved and said that the
squad sucked and then Nancy Pelosi
immediately gentleman said they're not
they're the greatest they're the most
beautiful young women standing up for
femininity
they're just the the revisionist
nonsense from the media my god
does impeaching Trump is a gamble for
Pelosi really is it a gamble what's the
gamble where is the vast outcry from
Democrats suggesting that that there's
going to be held to pay if Nancy Pelosi
does this according to time it has
intensified Republicans fealty to the
president he was already pulling in the
90s or the Republicans rallying his base
supercharging his campaign fundraising
potentially increasing his re-election
chances by the way that suggests it's
not a risk for Nancy Pelosi she's not
running for president it's a risk for
whoever runs against Trump but in the
house is not risking anything the
polarizing effect could jeopardize
Democrats who hold seats in Trump
territory and their buy-in
Pelosi's House Majority yes but she made
the calculation that she's more in
danger from the left wing of her base
than she is from Republicans retaking
the House Pelosi has always been a
risk-taker from defying Chinese
authorities by protesting at Tiananmen
Square in 1991 defying Chinese Authority
she was really she's an American citizen
too pushing Obamacare through the house
with nary a vote to spare in 2010 that's
not a risk she was doing what the
president wanted her to do but she was
careful to cast impeachment not as a
political gambit but as a project to
preserve the checks and balances of
American democracy
that's my responsibility to protect the
Constitution could anything be more
fawning than this it's hard to imagine
anything more fawning than this but
here's the bottom line she botched it
she really botched it and she didn't go
all in against Trump she had nothing to
risk because her pace freakin hates
Trump despises Trump but just the the
amount of navel-gazing sycophants see
here is beyond beyond compare Molly ball
running no aspect of the spectacle was
too small to escape Pelosi's control
she's a genius when the Intelligence
Committee held its public impeachment
hearings in November Pelosi noticed the
chairman that chairman Adam chefs head
reached nearly to the top of his high
back chair after intelligence finished
its work Judiciary chaired by
representative Jerry Nadler was slated
to hold hearings in the same room Pelosi
thought if he sat in the same chair
Nadler ahead shorter than Schiff would
look small Pelosi sent word down there
would have to be a change in furniture
and when Judiciary convened on December
4th Nadler was sitting in the leather
seated in the leather back chair that
reached no higher than here is my god
she even did the feng-shui in the
Judiciary Committee what genius
alternatively she put together an
impeachment effort with owning
Democratic votes that is going
absolutely nowhere and now she has to
browbeat her fellow Democratic Congress
people into pretending she's good at her
job Adam Smith had to put out a
statement today saying I misspoke
this morning I do believe we should do
everything we can to force the Senate to
have a fair trial if the speaker
believes that holding on to the articles
for a longer time will help force a fair
trial in the Senate I wholeheartedly
support that decision I am concerned
that Senator McConnell won't have a fair
trial I am with the speaker that we
should do everything we can to ensure he
does ultimately I do want the article
sense of the Senate for the very simple
reason that I want the impeachment
process to go forward to the very end he
says oh yeah by the way when I said
before it's still true but Nancy Pelosi
yelled at me and so now I'm going to
pretend to back off this whole thing has
been a debacle for Democrats it will
continue to be a debacle for
is a clown show and yet the media will
continue to pretend that Nancy Pelosi is
unbelievably good at her job when in
fact she used to be good at her job like
2010 she was good at her job now she's
had an awful year she's very bad at her
job right now and it is perfectly
obvious to anybody who has eyes to see
and is willing to not listen to the
stupid morons over in the media who
continued to just carry water for
Democrats the media partisanship in the
Trump era is just as bad as it was
during the Obama era it's just more
overt that's all alrighty well we've run
out of time for things I hate I think
that counted is a thing I like and a
thing I hate but at least I gave you the
impeachment update we will be back here
a little bit later today with two
additional hours of contents otherwise
I'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Romina hair and makeup is
by Jessa alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20/20 if you want to cut through
the madness of our politics and culture
and know what's really going on head on
over to the Michael Noel's show where we
can all bask in the simple joys of being
right see you there
[Music]